tutti ragazzi di quest'uomo video sono
dj magistrati su file knight e travis
for o anche sputato non so se si è visto
spero di no praticamente ragazzi ad
halloween
io ho fatto gioco de merda mentre i
creatori di fai da te il freddo ha fatto
una versione di file network freddy's
che non sapevo esistesse approfitto del
momento per registrarla perché magari
poi la toglieranno niente le scale non
mi ricordo assolutamente quello che lei
da un secolo che non gioco la phinet che
è successo avete visto anche voi ci sto
che lasciando il computer che cazzo è
successo non mi ricordo ma manco per il
pene come è strutturata sì e mi sto
ricordando che non crea che cosa c'è di
halloween di nuovo phinet e freddy's
ciao sono fa vj qual è il senso ragazzi
spiegato allora po a posto c'è o è molto
halloween marea papa avesse stronzate
che sappiamo fare
qualcuno per caso visto sua madre
battere in autostrada no perché io l'ho
vista ieri cascato tutto il microfono è
cascata pure lisa fusco da qualche parte
che i ragazzi è diventato un file knight
e zucca c'è proprio un nuovo tipo di
videogame fantastico io non mi ricordo
avevo smesso di giocarci afine perché
non riuscivo a vincere mai impossibile
se non vorrei dire colomba c'era anche
prima non lo so vabbè non importa foto e
sega ragazzi devo vincere
posso farcela a vincere un anno una
notte solo una meraviglia
che cosa successe successo salve ho
capito che sei vegano e che dei mangia
però troppe zucche c'è gesù cristo è un
po di nutella
ma senti e dobbiamo continuare così
finché non esplode occhi che non ti
usano come contenitore per lampade o
cosa no perché le zucche si usano per
come così
non frega un cazzo a nessuno ri come
usano le zucche ok ma lo stavo dicendo
per curiosità vostra potevi
semplicemente dirmi non me ne frega un
cazzo e io avrei capito ma vabbè ognuno
c'ha i modi sui cui ognuno c'ha i modi
sui fa vj 2015 dai però sono arrivato
alla terza ora quasi quasi mi che a
quanto mi mancava phinet freddy's
ragazzi non ne avete idea per queste
notti lo passate a pensare chi secondo
cazzo lo rifaccio rivero zio [ __ ] su uka
impariamo la parola su ca composta da
quattro lettere e infila tra pur emer
cosa voglio la mia vita spiega mia io
continuo a fissare perché ho paura che
se mi giro qualcuno mi stupri
effettivamente cioè io alla fine dico le
cose poi succedono allora che cazzo ma
lasciamo dietro bis non trovi le cuffie
impossibile le ragazze che mi ricordo
che da piccolo io ad halloween ci andavo
a fare dolcetto scherzetto quindi
halloween era bellissimo porca vacca
come cambiano i tempi mi che oggi provo
una merda o una ma arriva di qua quelli
mi stuprava vicino al letto cosa vedete
la mia vita basta mi sono rotto i
[ __ ]
pratola la cosa più horror di questo
horror e il ventilatore ragazzi chi è
che compra un ventilatore viola mai
vista una roba più brutta in vita mia
vabbè adesso l'ho vista adesso adesso mi
è capitato proprio di vedere ma cosa più
brutta di quella se non illuminami in
groppa non lo stesso e allora com'è che
ne so io eva io so posso fare con la
porta chiusa
se è andato a [ __ ] esiste un gioco
normale in questo cazzo di universo
devono veloce veloce lurida [ __ ]
[ __ ] brava brava brava
cos'è o mio dio che belli alberi no no
no no come ti permetti di stupro la
madre perfetto ho vinto è bravo bravo
vale è bravo ma ne fanno vedere a quel
minchione di market in casa fai libro la
mia vita
la cosa che mi prende di più è partito è
partito col minchia d'ora per lui la
rana che ti cucino manco fossi lì cinese
è fatta progaming ragazzi progaming
questa storia basso sartore cup vacca
dai e come fa non è impossibile non
potevo vincere la messa devo avere una
macchina al posto delle mani per vincere
ma ce la posso parlare la tranquilla a
faccia inserisci il tuo punteggio per
una chance di vincere 500 princier 500
stelline di gadget di hello kitty
cioè se mandatemi bastardi voglio i miei
slip di hello kitty
raga io non so come mai mi sono andato a
prendere i videogiochi con black ops
battlefield uncharted quando c'è questo
scriviamo tutti quanti una petizione
ragazzi hello kitty per playstation 4 lo
vogliono subito e non vale c'era il
piccione bluegem ha distratto sanno bene
non sono fatto per l'hard core gaming
dove vivere i problemi possono metto
becker ecco che cazzo ci fate caso di
angri persa ma cove perche c'e la stima
qualcosa pain effetto effetto
io mi sono salvato
1305 record del mondo a caso wabara gap
basta basta progaming dove come ci si
iscrive al progaming che vinco io a
chiodo ragazzi il nuovo pigoni hello
kitty perché abbiamo capito tutti qua
non c'è trippa per gatti che battuta di
pessimo gusto verrà sì vabbè ragazzi
torniamo sulla sul gioco in sé per sé
perché ancora non ho capito qui il
problema della vita come faccio a sapere
adesso quando arriva chiudo tengo chiuso
tengo che io ti sto così stiamo così per
quanto 10 secco almeno 10 secondi così
fermi tra sbatte pure palpebre brown
sbatti sbatti le valbrem e non ebbero ad
alba e bra bene adesso torna indietro
perfetto ti giri
la minchia sono arrivati a due ora due
ore due ore qualcosa in più ho fatto non
so come non so perché ma qualcosa in più
ho fatto ma poi ditemi che secoli voi ce
la fai da tè freddi se ci gioca che
cazzo sbaglio cos'è che non aiuto ok
adesso mi giro ci sono i pupazzetti sul
letto che mi spiano come con gianni
perfetto allora io lo so anch'esso anche
comesto gioco c'è neanche bisogno di
occhiali sui problemi della mia vita
sono risolti perché la porta si è chiusa
quindi direi che non c'è più nessuno
perché si sono spaventati no non ti gira
ok
stavo per morire ve lo dico ai ragazzi
io chiudo porte a caso che fa ma senti
molto attaccato alla maniglia tutta la
notte 2000 e nemi inglobano di rimango
attaccata alla vaniglia alla vaniglia
stavo dicendo se si sbatteva sbatti
anche tua madre 6 voglio tanto non mi
sta come attacco proprio al caso che a
me non è possibile ragazze non so cosa
devo fare più di così
cazzo fa ma sei scemo
quindi ragazzi ho capito che se non
peggio la mia torcia ci sono dei
problemi con ragazzi io ho saputo dal
dal creatore di find out freddy's me
l'ha detto proprio lui che le cinque
notti sono impossibili da vincere ma che
riesce a vincere
vince anche il ventilatore viola c'è
proprio lui lo dà in omaggio a chi
riesce a fare cinque notti senza morire
ma è invece di stare qua a contemplare
all'armadio no profit camici dentro
l'armadio gli aveva niente lasciamo
perdere
lasciamolo solo lì aperto non si sa mai
che qualcuno entri all'ampio e qualcosa
ha lampeggiato non hanno visto cosa non
ho capito niente golino a te 2 di notte
due di notte per eva mese bike.it vai
forza tesoro tesoro brava brava cazzola
mia guerriera che arriva no ap di merda
no no no no non devo rivela devo
prendere questa roba che non si capisce
cos'è perché troppo piccola però è figo
devo arrivare a casa o noi da detriti
alle spalle grazie molto gentile non a
figo mai verrai perfetti bello 3 madre
ape regina mica per regina del mondo che
batte negli alveari [ __ ] su grande
notte siamo grati alla notte quattro
ragazzi aumento da quello che avete nè
alcuno non è il pungiglione mai un pene
affetto ma è impossibile ma cosa no
magari ex parà che video vi sia piaciuto
non mi piace per file rete freddy's che
è un gioco più semplice di hello kitty
che quanto visto non è così semplice
c'è anche il sito la fenice il sito
scoperto adesso
oddio oddio oddio oh mio dio lo voglio
[ __ ]
eccolo mi metto anche mi piace da solo
così e così mela in via o mio dio
oh mio dio sono bagnatissimo anche
ragazzi spero il mio video vi sia
piaciuto oh mi piace per farne dei
freddi se perello kitty che ha vinto
tutto come se i ragazzi servito è
piaciuto
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e canoni vita trovato nello
stesso io dopo mi faccio un giro a caso
su internet a cercare tutti gli oggetti
di hello kitty è il più bello lo compro
lo voglio in casa da qualche parte
società si di scrivere ci vediamo il
prossimo video bella ragazza oggi sono
stato più virile del solito comunque